Joe Biden he's still on vacation so he
just had that massive spending Bill
flown to the Virgin Islands on a
passenger jet so that he could sign it
into law now thousands of Americans are
trapped in airports tonight but somehow
this particular jet took off with no
problems the 4 000 page 1.7 trillion
dollar spending bill is now law now
Chris Bedford is executive editor at the
common sense Society he joins us now to
assess a bit of a double standard here
my my first thought Chris was why did he
leave Washington in the first place
knowing that this his signature was
going to be needed very imminently
because why not I mean why not send a
private jet down to Saint Croix to bring
him to Bill to sign it why not leave
Washington D.C why care at all about all
the people who are stuck in airports I
mean this entire bill is completely
representative of how little DC cares
about actual American interests about
the American people about their voters I
mean if you're a republican for example
decided to stay hope uh stay home during
the November election what better
Vindication do you have for that
decision than this bill that Mitch
McConnell pushed through with Joe Biden
and Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi at
the end the absolute arrogance and the
the the where they're actually putting
the priorities here now for example
there's over 13 billion dollars in this
bill going to fix the Ukrainian energy
grid now there's about 1 13th or one
tenth that amount or less going to
Puerto Rico Puerto Rico is a famously
corrupt energy grid where a lot of that
money is siphoned off nothing works and
hurricanes said it's a disaster but at
least that's part of the United States
uh Ukraine is where that money is going
instead there are so many pet projects
there's over 80 million million dollar
is going to save the Grouse which is a a
beautiful bird that's being destroyed
right now their habitats being destroyed
by windmills and solar panels which get
billions and billions and billions of
dollars and their own profit so at that
point when there's so little carried
when after an election D.C politicians
are so arrogant I mean you might as well
just put that 4 000 page Bill onto our
private jet fly down to Saint Croix and
sign it while you're on vacation
yeah Chris so there's so too many
examples of of you know the the pork the
special projects the fluff that was
shoved into that bill but I think one of
the most egregious ones that I saw has
to do with the crisis that's happening
at the border where they allotted money
to go towards Customs and Border
Protection but they went out of their
way to put language in that bill that
says you're not actually allowed to use
any of this money towards Technologies
and capabilities that will actually help
secure the border which is just I mean
it is so offensive and wrong on on so
many levels thank you so much for
bringing some sense to this insane
situation Chris I appreciate it
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight